forging ahead we must remain committed
to the strategy a peaceful reunification
and one country systems
we maintain long-term prosperity and
stability of Hong Kong and Macau
of cross-strait relations through heart
unite the whole country strive for
complete unification of our country
[Applause]
forging ahead must remain committed to
the path for development open strategy
to join the community of a shared future
for mankind People's Liberation Army of
China police force your you Baba retain
the pathos purposes fun Sun and the
nature of being Jewish military what I
will resolutely South called the
sovereignty modern security and
development of the nation resolutely
protect world peace coming German
comrades
Oh young man friends
okay China yesterday is ready engraved
in history of mankind from origin here
China today since I it's created by
hundreds of new working Chinese will be
even more prosperous Chen Bao the party
changing the army of all ethnic groups
yeah you must be what no firmly United
remain true to our ultimate aspiration
and keep our mission firmly we must
continue to consolidate don't develop
this Republic and continue to achieve
similar goals not to realize the Chinese
strong national rejuvenation
[Applause]
rather true harder me to have romance a
long live the great People's Republic of
China the great munis Party of China to
me much longer to create Chinese people
we measure now the military review stop
[Music]
are your positions